Here's everything I make in a morning.
As someone who was just in Europe for the past three weeks
and wants to get back on track,
I start by making a fresh batch of coconut milk
so I can swap a coffee for a matcha latte.
I over indulged in coffee and heavy cream while away
and am definitely feeling the damage.
After feeding my sleepy
sourdough starter with some freshly milled flour and water,
I get to making the children breakfast
with the abundance of eggs my chickens have provided me
well away to make these egg cupcakes,
I combine eight eggs,
some raw cream, and salt.
I save the eggshells
which I throw to my backyard chickens for added Calcium and nutrition.
I then grease a muffin pan and layer shredded
pasture raised chicken Parmigiano Reggiano in the egg mix.
Those bake in the oven for just 15 minutes
and taste absolutely delicious.
The kids love these so much, so we make them often.
Blackberries are in season right now,
so I'll be picking every day until they're gone.
I prep them so I have them all year long by washing,
drying, and then freezing them.
The kids were dying for some healthy muffins,
so that's exactly what I did.
I whipped up a batch of whole grain,
freshly milled muffins with a super ripe banana and a good ingredient
chocolate on top.
I was in the mood for some lentils,
so I added two cups to a Bowl with warm water
and some apple cider vinegar.
These will soak for one to two days to neutralize fidic
acid and make nutrients more bioavailable to our body.
After 18 minutes of baking,
I pulled the mini muffins out to let them cool on a rack.
Follow along for part 2 to see what the rest of the day looks like.